here's Hilary that's the focus of
tonight's angle right appearing recently
on PBS and in response to a question
about Trump's urging her to run again
mrs. Clinton said this so maybe there
doesn't need to be a rematch I mean
obviously I can beat him again well host
Judy Woodruff noted via Twitter that
Clinton claimed she was joking but
remember we're talking about the
Clintons so the truth is always a bit
elusive well what are the chances that
Hillary jumps in at the 2020 race it
ain't zero and does she think about it
all the time
absolutely that's what one of Hillary's
closest confidants told The Washington
Post just a few months ago I dismissed
the idea of Hillary to point out kind of
out of hand
she wouldn't be that arrogant and I'm
gracious toward the current field no way
but then the weakness of the Democrats
slate surprised even me nothing's
working the walking talking gaffe Ematic
machine known as Jill Biden may have
dropped in the polls for a few weeks but
now he's back on top and what seems to
be the grudging recognition that the
other top candidates Warren and Sanders
are just not going to cut it and keep
battleground states where common sense
still mean something now mrs. Clinton
may also feel vindicated by the
interestingly timed release of an
internal State Department report that
somehow managed to exonerate her in the
matter of email deletion and the
handling of classified information
although Hillary staffers of course they
were faulted the review certainly gives
mrs. Clinton cover plus I mean who
doesn't think that Hillary is a stronger
candidate than that goofball Biden to
use one of his favorite phrases come on
man
like I know what you're saying you know
though come on isn't it too late it's
too late for Hillary it's too late to
get into this already crowded field well
my answer is it's really up to the party
the voters are jazzed by any of the
likely frontrunners they'd be stupid not
to seriously consider another Clinton
bid she has an instant name recognition
a massive fundraising apparatus that
could be reactivated and her old
campaign team would quickly reconstitute
and keep players
eggs at other campaigns the moment she
stepped back in and let's face it she's
been to the Trump rodeo before so she
knows the show better than anyone as
another Hilary Powell told The
Washington Post her view is I ran
against this guy I know how to do this
another reason I think Hillary is
inching toward a rerun it's her penchant
for dipping into the political
conversation uninvited most recently it
was her gratuitous swipe at Tulsi
Gabbard while Bernie Sanders gently
reproached Hillary for the smear
Elizabeth Warren just seemed nervous
about the looming Clinton shadow senator
Secretary Clinton is been back in the
news recently she critics I have a
question about public education I just
want to start there do you think she's
helping or hurting the Democratic Party
I don't have any comment on that role
for her in the 2020 I don't have any
comment
gulp shaking now of course the other
animating force for Hillary maybe the
Democrats view albeit erroneous that the
Trump campaign is gravely wounded by the
growing likelihood of impeachment now I
can imagine this maybe you can as well
these will paid over paid I should say
political consultants making this pitch
go something like this
Madam Secretary even if the economy
remains strong our internal polling it's
showing that voters will abandon Trump
and choose you another political name
brand just to stop the chaos coming out
of Washington and just think you'll
finally mrs. Clinton be able to make
history as the first female president of
the United States
don't let the dream die America is
calling you history is calling you save
us from Trump do it for the grandkids
and as for mrs. Clinton's recent bravado
and trash-talking of President Ron
he knows that he's an illegitimate
president he's either lying or
delusional or both so it's like applying
for a job and getting 66 million letters
of recommendation and losing to a
corrupt human tornado Oh big deal let's
just talk unless that is she wants to
back it up with action way back in
Hillary the water's warm
and the other thread of this narrative
that must not be overlooked is that the
instant and hearty support she would
receive immediately from the old
embattled deep state in professional and
diplomatic corps who are now battling
Trump you don't think this group would
rather go back to the good old days of
Clinton again and kiss this entire
America first era goodbye so there you
have it a combination of Hillary's pride
her desire for revenge a weak Democratic
field and a consultancy class that can
sell sand in the desert maybe pointing
us toward another Trump Clinton faceoff
of course Hillary's smart enough to know
that the only thing worse than losing
once to Donald Trump would be losing
twice to him and that too is a distinct
possibility are you suggesting that
someone's trying to make a real-life
sequel we're going to do that sequel
many sequels have surpassed their
original yeah name one yeah well not
this one that's for sure if you thought
2016 was exciting you ain't seen nothing
yet and that's the angle